and it's really funny when i see them
say democracy is broken
you know this perhaps a system power
democracy
they don't say democracy they say our
democracy which means their democracy
and they say things like perhaps a
system created by 200 year old you know
250 year old slave owners was not a good
system
and they argue that the the the
republicans represent the minority of
this country
you know they represent you know 13
million less people and i'm like
that's on purpose it's literally why the
system
was created the way it is to prevent
majority abuse
i don't think these people realize what
it would be like to live in a country of
pure democracy
where it's like whatever's popular is
mandated you want minority rule
and there's a really good a really good
example there was a period when uh
marijuana was the minority and people
were going to jail for smoking it but
now one by one these states are starting
to legalize it and starting to become
the majority opinion
you you need to create a space where the
minority can speak up
and say we're gonna do this that's why
the other college makes sense so that
california
as its own jurisdiction can say we're
legalizing recreational you know pot
and then all the other states can start
doing it and eventually get a supreme
court ruling and boom there it is
nationwide legalized
yeah under the way they want to see it
we would just be an authoritarian
lockdown country with
everyone would be terrified of what the
majority opinion was and it would be
lowest common denominator law
yeah everything would just be like
whatever most people agree with is the
law
most people agree with it's whoever they
can get the most to the polls
right so it's not even about who the
voice of the people it's just about the
voice
yeah yeah and they were just talking
about like uh voter coercion from like
the 1800s they'd be out there with their
guns you know
making sure people voted or didn't vote
or having people vote twice with the
disguise on and
all sorts of things yeah literally no
he's not joking no i know like
coercion voting co voter coercion that
kind of thing
is there more no i was just saying
people were saying something about uh
michael's hard to hear because of his
mask oh it is it is true
is that what they're saying no one don't
get me sick no one cared who i was until
i put on the mask
then they were complaining who is this
guy he wants him sound right here all
right
i did that it was a beautiful night i
committed to the bit that's a good bit
you did you full-on dead you know what
it was it was because you couldn't get
your mouth to the microphone okay
because you were like floating behind it
it was also creating like a weird echo
now you sound normal so my thought is if
trump loses
twitter's going to ban him within a week
not even within a week
they'll just ban him facebook already
removed president from his account yeah
they're
they're going to see that they won't ban
him while he's president trump's account
no longer says president
it says political candidate amazing dude
we are still i'm sorry by every measure
yes
and i'm telling you man we might not be
in what people think is like a legit
full-on ground war but this is a
a battle and it's extrajudicial it's
extra legal it is outside the confines
of what
of anything and it is manipulation
propaganda in an attempt to seize power
period
in yeah in my book than you write i this
i talk about this in 1992
pat buchanan who's a very uh complex and
troubling figure in many ways
got on the floor of the republican
convention and said we're in a cultural
war
and we don't know if barbara bush
literally
clutched her pearls uh andrew cuomo who
was governor of new york at the time
said culture what does that word mean
the nazi used to use that word
you know and they were all freaked out
and in that one regard
he was absolutely right that there has
been a systemic
assault for over a hundred years uh by
certain very nefarious forces
on the population this country and only
now thanks to the internet in my opinion
and technology are people realizing oh
they've been at this for a long time and
these are really bad people i have to
you know i have to wonder about all this
and and uh because i've been hearing
from a lot of people
trump's master plan released the kraken
all this stuff
and i'm like it's just never happens
nothing crazy like this ever happens
it's always usually boring 2016 was
crazy 20. it was
it never happened right that was not
hillary's emails was so nuts
crazy here bizarre scandal you look at
who joe biden is trying to appoint now
to his cabinet
major corporations banks lobbyists he's
a corporatist
yeah it's all the same and you hear what
he said he's not going to go after trump
yeah he's not going to investigate trump
for any of these crimes and he's going
to try and bring unity to the country
this is a thing that i like a lot about
joe biden uh and i think
this is gonna be hard people here for me
because i'm such a fire breather he
genuinely is i think upset by how
divided this country is
he genuinely thinks this is an
opportunity for him to bring people
together
he genuinely has worked very well with
republicans he boasted about working
well as segregationists for christ
during the campaign so i think it hurts
him on
like a visceral level he's been in a
center since 1972
and he's like this i'm just one more
point just like this is his opportunity
to be like all right i'm gonna
put my money where my mouth is and try
to reach out to the other side i don't
think so
because he opened his campaign talking
about charlottesville talking about
fine people he lied right out of the
gate right what
i think what he was trying to do there
was divide the trump republicans
and the old school republicans the
pre-trump republicans and make that
coalition
i think he's a corrupt dirty rotten liar
who's
in it to enrich himself and his family
and there's a difference between that
and the depravity of like the clintons
like an old-school machine politician
who just makes a bank
they're all they all do that i think
that's very different between someone
who's that and just really just nefario
like when bill clinton bombed
sudan during impeachment like he blew up
a factory that's making medicine
just to change the headlines this guy
should be in jail and we don't talk
about it
yeah do you remember pre were you
politically active in the 80s
much or before that uh before that
i don't know i don't know i don't know
if you're 16 or 30. i know i just i have
time
i know i'm a rich i'm an ancient evil
from time to memorial but no
i was not politically active in the 80s
me neither um but the clintons seemed
like
but the clintons seemed like they were
like young cool hippies and then they
just got cold
what are you talking about hillary was a
young republican didn't she was a
goldwater girl
yes she worked with goldwater
david brock his book was called the
seduction of hillary rodham and it's all
about how she got turned you know yeah
and they and they got
they seemed like they got power hungry
and co-opted but that was
what about what about the conspiracy
that bill was never actually president
that he was just the puppet for hillary
what
that's not dude you know that's hillary
threw a lamp at him in the secret
service they know what to do
sure chairman miles why about this yeah
no i didn't during the month i wasn't
politically active in the 90s okay
during the whole impeachment drama with
hillary and bill and monica and all this
there was a huge fight in the white
house the private suite
and hillary threw a lamp at bill he had
a mark in his face the next day
wow and there was a discussion in the
secret service what's the protocol
if the first lady is literally
assaulting the president domestic abuse
they didn't know what to do wow what did
they do nothing
well they got murdered
all right that's it clearly they were
murdered i think she was the power
behind bill that doesn't support
me no no no no what happened this is
what this is what people this is what
the boomer cons don't realize about
hillary
okay in 93 she campaigned in 92 they
campaigned they go two for the price of
one
right this oh we're gonna i didn't take
my husband's name for a long time yeah
yeah
she gets in the white house she says i
want to run something that was the quote
she just wanted power they put her in
charge of health care which is something
she had no experience with
she held the meetings in secret to
remake
a sixth of the economy just we're just
gonna no secret meetings
she bungled it so badly that the
republicans got congress for the first
time in 40 years
and after that they vanished her and
rush limbaugh at the time used to have
segments on a show called hillary
sightings
wow because they would just have her
like reading children's books like once
a month after that
because they completely disappeared her
because she was so unpopular
she only became popular after when she
could play the victim card
when bill was kind of you know yeah
liking to the white house sink
is that what he was doing that was in
the star report yeah he feed off into
the sink next to the oval office you
didn't know this oh
yeah i was a little kid what a good one
i mean i know i know the general uh i
don't
know
he did he finished into this thing oh
okay he wrapped a horrible
photo to him on the stand you know what
i said
this is the first i've heard of it
that's awesome how did that come out i i
mean probably
no that's not how i meant well thank you
for clarifying
um oh god uh
so she stood by her man then they made
her governor
senator um i'm not really political
do you know where babies come from
when a president loves an intern very
much it looks like he has a box of
cigars it looks like chairman mao's wife
was the power behind the cultural
revolution
and i wonder if hillary had that kind of
psychotic prowess
how insane was it that they tried to run
hillary in 2016. and they were like who
was it martin o'malley and like who was
the other uh lincoln chafee
it was like they had just and they were
like they were they're trying to find
candidates to prop up to make it seem
like hillary was actually running
and they like walked into the hallway
and they grabbed like the janitor and
the you know but they also grabbed
bernie and he almost won
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time